let's say that I'm just sitting on the
surface of the earth maybe that's me
right over there you can barely see me
I'll enlarge a little bit hanging out in
northwest Africa maybe I'm hanging out
in Morocco and we know that the earth is
pulling down on me that the force of
gravity from the the mass that we call
the earth is pulling me towards its
center of mass pulling me towards the
center of the earth and if we were to
zoom in on things if we resume on things
if this is the ground and we know that
this is really just the surface of Earth
and if this is me this is me right over
here hanging out we know that there is a
force of gravity acting downwards on me
towards the center of the earth and
let's say that that force is 700 700
Newtons now my question to you is am I
am i pulling the we know the earth is
pulling on me this is the force of
gravity pulling me downwards but do I
also pull on the earth is there also a
corresponding force that I am pulling on
the earth
and it is if there is a corresponding
force is it smaller than the force of
what earth is pulling on me or is it the
same or is it even larger than the force
that earth is pulling on me so I'll let
you think about that for a little bit
well Newton's third law tells us that if
the earth is pulling on me with a force
of 700 Newtons towards the center of
mass of Earth then I too am pulling on
the earth with a force of 700 Newtons
but in the opposite direction so if this
is me and I'm getting pulled down with a
force of 700 Newtons then I - and
pulling the earth towards my center of
mass with a force of 700 Newtons but in
the direction in the opposite direction
so earth is pulling downward on me and
I'm pulling I guess you could say upward
on the earth or towards me the earth is
pulling me towards it and I am pulling
the earth towards me and so if I were to
draw it here I'm I'm obviously not going
all the way down to the center of the
earth here to draw this vector but I am
pulling on the earth with an equal and
opposite force of
700 Newtons but this might seem
suspicious to you because you might
think of let's say that let's just say
that I'm not sitting in Morocco right
here I'm not on the surface of the earth
let's say that I'm I'm up here and I'm
falling towards the earth and once again
we can say that the earth is pulling on
me with a force of 700 Newtons will
assume that the force that the
gravitational field hasn't changed
dramatically with this little altitude
we'll assume it roughly constant near
the surface of the earth but I'm falling
and the force that the earth is pulling
on me gravitational force towards its
center is 700 Newtons and I'm saying
wait I'm pulling with an equal force on
the earth of 700 Newtons how can this be
it looks like I am accelerating much
more than the earth is accelerating how
does all of this make sense and I'll let
you think about that for a second the
important thing to realize here is just
because the forces have the same
magnitude but they're acting in
different directions it doesn't mean
that the acceleration has to have the
same magnitude remember Newton's law
Newton's second law tells us that force
is equal to mass mass times acceleration
mass times acceleration and for my
situation both for the force that Earth
is pulling on me and the the force that
I'm pulling on earth it might be the
same but remember earth has a huge
except a few Jay ass so earth earth
earth has huge has huge huge m while I
have a much much smaller M so if Earth
has a huge M so for a given F you're
going to have very very very tiny
acceleration for the same F if you have
a more Sal sized or Sal mass M then
you're going to have a much larger
acceleration so even though the forces
acting on the bodies are have the same
magnitude they're going in opposite
directions the actual accelerations can
be very very different because the two
objects have very very very different
masses